this week we are partnered with hellofresh
and Rocket money more on them after the
reaction what are you doing no breaks Roxy no
time to check your phone we're going to watch
hasmin Hotel the official Premiere episode we
waited four years to watch this Roxy and now
we're finally here if you did not catch our
reaction to the pilot that is up here on the
channel I did with this person over here she's
Jewish they don't get a hell anyway we go to
go watch this now say that like it's a punishment
so they don't get a hell they don't get to have a
Hell and Hell looks fun in this show no we're just
in the dirt and the maggots and bugs eat us until
you're part of the Earth again you know boring
yeah it's crazy that we filmed the pilot episode
four years ago and then we're wearing the same
outfits for the first episode I have not washed
these clothes in the last four years you know
what to do people leave a like on this video
you're going to want to do that Satan request
it also subscribe click that notification Bell
cuz Roxy and I are going to be playing catch up
throughout the week hopefully we get to do these
daily uploads that means you get so much of the
maggots over here and uh thank you to prepper or
whomever maybe me yes calling the Jews maggots
is what I said I said you're the maggot just you
not the Jews don't put words in my mouth such a
Jewish thing to do okay fine I'm a m thank you
full Bank threat to watch the h seink of with
your own copy of hasman hotel that's available
for super sex reject at our patreon page over
there we cover several things exclusive with
highlights and watch along included you're ready
to see how they have evolved this now that they
got an insane budget behind it change some voice
actors and then we're going to compare it and
go this is not the Nostalgia that I remember
or this is better and improved you ready I'm
on a Highway to Hell B Guns and Roses great
band all right stay word to Heaven let's go
we're g to get an intro oh cool it's it said an
Amazon series let's go a24 my favorite okay Bento
Box you l oh fun that's it so short oh she still
gets credit good I wonder if she wrote it all the
episodes once upon a time there was a glowing City
protected by Golden Gate uh-huh it was ruled by
beings of pure light right angels that worshiped
good and shielded all from Evil exactly I was
saying she was she has an Angel Heart Lucifer he
was a dreamer with Fantastical ideas for all of
creation but he was seen as a troublemaker by
the Elders of heaven where they felt his way
of thinking was dangerous what was his way of
thinking so he watched as the Angels began to
expand the universe in their ways from the dust of
Earth they created Adam and Lilith Lilith equals
as the first of mankind Adam demanded control and
Lilith refused to submit to his will silly woman
Lucifer found her and the two rebellious dreamers
fell deeply in love together they wished to share
the magic of Free Will with Humanity he had a good
heart offering the fruit of knowledge to Adam's
new bride Eve but this gift came with a curse for
with this single act of Disobedience evil finally
found its way into Earth with it a new Realm
of Darkness and sin o as punishment for their
Reckless act Heaven cast Lucifer and his love
into the dark pit he had created never allowing
him to see the good that came from Humanity wow
wow it's like tragic Lilith thrived empowering
demonkind with her voice and her songs and as the
numbers of Hell grew so did its power cast in like
a feels like light like beautiful they would send
down an army an extermination to sure hell and its
Sinners could never rise against I no we're taking
heaven I'm on hellside but Lilith's hope remained
and her dream was pass down to their precious
daughter the princess of Hell there you go we
know her we love her don't worry Mom I'll make you
proud Charlie oh she got a second hair elastic now
did you hear all that uh yeah that was right there
her voice sounds different I get pretty worked up
after an extermination happens the story helps she
can feel like the tragic pain of everyone's really
feeling are you okay you know family stuff did
you hear from your mom yet how long has it been
now written by only seven years seven years but
this kingdom was something she really cared about
something I care about at least you aren't alone
I just hope what I'm trying to do here will work
sounds like Stephanie beatric all right come on
Alistar says he has something to show us I hear
that it's like I have Lake Bell in my head because
she's so poison ivy this is so hard in poison ivy
but well hello there you w sin do you like blood
violence and depravity of a sexual nature yes yeah
that's why you're in hell but what would you say
if I told you there was a place to stay that had
none of that has been Hotel missguided path to
Redemption misguided path by Lucifer's delusional
daughter Charlotte oh no place your fate in her
inexperienced hand as she tries to work through
her daddy issues by fixing you things somewhat
functional sta this does look appealing enjoy
riveting conversation with our singular residence
all L and more at the has been Hotel desperate
attempt at Salvation Starts Here we still don't
have a working phone what a commercial what the
was that alist I mean maybe the tone is a bit
off got that smile this makes it look bad funny
I was going for hilarious the commercial was to
let Sinners know we are trying to help them well
my dear I haven't been active in hell for some
time and everyone remembers me from my radio
show as long as you get butts in the seats can I
suggest you take better advantage of The Talented
celebrity you have right here you're a porn star
a famous porn star I would not watch the videos
we are not filming a as a commercial why not
sells don't it a little bit little bit you film
me going at it with Mr fancy talk creepy voice
here you'd be rolling in participants willing to
stay at this hotel make that fan video and there's
nothing wrong with some sexy time as long as it's
consensual I really don't want to exploit you in
that way you don't want the hotel exploited this
body was made to be exploited I got the arms I got
the stamina I got the legs I got the lung capacity
the gag reflex the holes the chest fluff everyone
think chest fluff wonder if that was a response
to comments probably yeah if freaky face over
there is so powerful then why can't he just make
people stay here oh trust me I can you actually
think I'd be cleaning bottles and listening to
you [__] [__] and moan all the time if he
wasn't forcing me I like being forced keep that
here s Me Whiskers again and I'll Jam that
bottle down your throat come on keep talking
dirty I relate most with him we can't force
Sinners to stay here they need to choose
to that's what I'm telling you Greg you have
to want to get help yeah it's the way how it
usually works just because nobody has made it
out before doesn't mean it's not possible see
we're trying to get out whatever means I can
keep crashing here rentree crack is expensive
my dad just called he said that the leader
of the Angel Army wants to meet he asked if
I could go instead but the extermination
just happened what could they want this
soon after I can do this I'll get Heaven
behind Charlie hold on there's just a CH
it's just a meeting wants to change their
minds and touch their hearts or what ever
angels have oh she's so endearing this could
be swell something tells me that today will be
a happy day in oh no oh no yes a happy day
in hell don't sing to them that [__] is
halfway down the street oh she's dancing you
actually saw her in the background that was
cool this sounds so Disney hi mister go
yourself I'm not doing well oh no poor
gu any Soul change are hard to change
I'm so worried about their friendship
iies yes you can hear the sorrow
I open the door and I give them a
place at my has Hotel there was light before
the darkness show us around the neighborhood
to don't wear holy sh
my Heaven's really the enemy change their
mind and touch my parts uh no he did the
whole it's going to be a goddamn nightmare oh
there's the lady in the [__] with like guts
or something awesome awesome awesome awesome
that was like a straight Broadway Banger yeah
oh okay also creepy read the contract before
you sign it especially in hell baby girl got
to keep these moving though yeah up holy [__]
I'm Charlie my dad asked me if I could meet you
yeah I know okay spoiled nice to meet you too oh
got you did you see that I recognize his voice too
you weren't here you think I'd come down there
no I mean I love the vibe totally I love your
tunes but it's such a bummer man everything down
there is just so you know what A pompous [__]
yeah there's a project I've been working on that
I really want to talk to you about hey hey hey
slow down we got time I love how he's drawn
demonic too we are making a new commercial we
need a camera Alistair a video camera all right
I love how alistair's drawn like a classic devil
that's what I said yeah I just I elaborated a
tiny bit more I once it came out of my mouth I
realized and I need a big strong Daddy to put me
in my right it dude well you come oh yeah to the
right place please cut okay Angel I need you to be
less horny if possible no can you maybe not have
the script in front of your face I it memorize
this [__] sounds like Keith David so I was
playing this gig and for some reason this virtue
chick was digging on the drummer and it's like do
you know who I am I'm Adam I'm the original it's
like odk that's no no it's not that's the original
Adam I'm the master who is this wait your name
is Adam Adam like the first man Adam yeah Adam
going to be an angel with Lilith Mr Adam sir
call me dickm Adam you seem like a smart master
I know you are the leader of the angels and you
are a big thinker a revolutionary a a dickm who
would really love to put his name on something
love putting my name on [__] shit's the best
solution to our biggest problem Oh herpes yeah
that's a [__] no our other biggest problem oh
uh ugly people that is a real problem your line is
we have the cleanest rooms okay got it I'm ready
action oh my God into the vo I actually have to
say the line so let's roll again okay action oh
Nifty is stage fright you're doing great cut
all right see this episode's entire response
to YouTube comments well they had four years
respond seems like you're having a bit of trouble
there H St why are you even here I think that's
Stephanie beatress I don't think you're wrong
here is Alis the egocentric piece of [__]
that this face was made for radio it's like
a creepy pasta man you're going to make this
work because it won't be so entertaining to
watch over an empty Hotel will it [__] ass
[__] ass saying that that's an amazing cuz
you pooped yourself yeah [__] ass I do this
for you and you never ask me to engage with
this frivolous television technology ever again
what is it about TV you fear so much fine now
then oh how neat all right everyone let's make
a commercial oh my God you when you take her
out for the fifth time and she still expects
you to pay the check but you're like hey I
thought you wanted equality our shared problem
of overpopulation in hell oh well that's not a
problem we got that covered what's happening
how many demons did you kill this year 275
this year sir 275 wao awesome job not awesome
those are my people he doesn't care that must
suck for you wow Adam Sinners made mistakes
sure but everyone makes mistakes and then
they're punished forever Angels don't make
mistakes I've never made a mistake in my
life the only reason you're still here is
because daddy gave you and your hellborne
kind a pardon from an exorcist blade how does
that feel to know how little you matter oh my
God oops almost out of time guess we should get
into it oh no no no angels are just as messed up
I know how's population is out of control it's
a bad situation it's taking a toll if we rehab
these Sinners and cleanse all their soul SS at
my hasband hotel I know you guys fly down just
to kill once a year and it must be annoying to
S all the way here if they join you in heaven
that trip disappears okay so it is to get them
to Heaven yeah save us all precious time oh it's
like a rock opera Sor sweetie but there's no
def their F hell is forever you like it or not
but why now wow there's noing to unreal what
are my problems with it it poses like great
philosophical questions did I hear you imply that
they don't deserve death are they winners are they
Sinners cuz it's cut and dry fa is fair and I
for an i no it's not fair at all who makes the
decision extermination is entertainment oh
that what a good line guaro [__] guitar solo
[__] this is a dope
song a lot of dynamic Duos in this that I
love what a prick move up the next extermination
what oh my God year to those little I know it's
just been a week but we'll be back in 6 months 6
months also kind of a commentary on how we treat
the prison system yeah totally we have something
exciting to show you wait the commercial you all
made a new one yeah one of my better performances
if I do say so myself that's amazing not going
tell them to the HB Hotel oh no we have just
received word from the heaven Embassy that oh
no extermination is happening sooner than ever
before son of a [__] what does that mean Katie
it means we're all royally that's definitely
a different voice holy crap that's like way
different see I love like like the Retro touches
they do where it could feel like semi sci-fi the
body six months is the end of the season of us
before they killed an angel don't worry when we
come back there won't be a demon left alive to
pull a stunt like this again oh they didn't kill
the angel they Sor in Stephanie beatric Keith
David okay I was right about those two I don't
recognize any of the other names who did the guy
that I'm talking about we'll look it up to keep
you happy thank you to America's number one meal
kid hellofresh for partnering with us it's always
great to partner with people whose Services you
actually use because as someone like me who's
always juggling a pack schedule between filming
and editing finding time for healthy eating can be
a challenge that's right for hellofresh has been
a game changer for my life with hellofresh I get
farm fresh pre-portioned ingredients and delicious
recipes delivered right to my doorsteps so I don't
have to step outside it's revolutionized my home
cooking experience making it not just easy but
super enjoyable and affordable keyw I recently
tried their delicious barbecue pineapple flat RADS
and their zucchini pomodora Panet bake both were
mouthwatering delicious and fit perfectly with
my pescatarian lifestyle pescatarian m s fancy
and asking my friends who love meat hellofresh
has an incredible variety tempts me to be a meat
eater again people I know I've really recommended
their lemon parsley chicken palard I think is how
you pronounce it and the Fuego chicken faito tacos
regardless hellofresh menu has something for
everyone but of course it's not just about the
food it's about saving time too not having a wait
in line at a grocery store even self checkouts on
fast enough these days the convenience of having
everything delivered pre-portioned right to your
door is priceless especially with our quick and
easy meals like 15-minute recipes spending less
time in the kitchen and more time doing what
I love which is filming and editing so here's
the deal if you want a great way to support the
channel Channel and also support you know having
a new lifestyle healthy affordable lifestyle in
the year 2024 go to hellofresh.com rejects free
and use code rejects free for free breakfast
for life you heard that right one breakfast
item per box while the subscription is active
free breakfast for life for hellofresh.com
reject free use promo code reject free try it
out and let me know your favorite dishes stay
healthy and let's keep enjoying those movies and
shows all right reject Nation let's get real for
a moment running this channel is incredible but
managing finances especially taxes and budgeting
both for the channel and my personal life can
be overwhelming that's where rocket money has
been a financial Lifesaver for me even before
I ever partnered up with them like I said I've
been very fortunate to be working with Brands
whose products I already use so it's a win-win
for AWA but it can be a win-win for you too cuz
there's a reason I use them rocket money is a
personal finance app that simplifies managing
money by canceling unnecessary subscriptions
lowering bills and crafting a budget that fits
your specific lifestyle for someone like me who
can easily lose track of expenses throughout
every single day of the month it's been eye
openening to see where I was overspending stuff I
don't use that I kept paying for especially apps
man I was way too many apps rocket money does
a heavy lifting by analyzing your spending then
customizes notifications to help you stay within
your budget goals it's not just about saving money
it's about actively seeing and feeling your
financial progress It's a great feeling they
track your monthly subscriptions too so many free
trials I signed up for that I forgot to you know
get rid of before the free trial was done making
it super easy to cancel the ones you don't use
couple of clicks and you're putting money back
in your pocket telling you have you ever found
subscriptions or pay for services you forgot
about because Rocky money is a huge asset in
helping to uncover those and even negotiate some
of my bills down to up like 20% so if you're ready
to take control of your finances and there's no
better time than now because it is the beginning
of the year check out rocket money and see how
much you could be saving stop wasting money
on things you do not use so to help support the
channel and help support your wallet visit rocket
money.com rejects rocket money currently has over
5 million users and has helped save its members
an average of $720 a year with over $500 million
in canceled subscriptions they've helped me and
I'm confident they'll do the same for you that's
rocket money.com rejects your bank account will
thank you oh there's four episodes out right now
I know from the time of us filming it that's why
I said that's why I said can you be here an extra
hour oh wow yeah and Roxy was so uncooperative so
difficult to keep her happy that's me anyway um
yo that's a great first episode yeah or episode
two really but they had a really hard job making
it so that this is a pilot and an episode 2 and
I think they did both those things they didn't
rehash any of the old beats but they did enough
explaining so that if you didn't go watch
the Youtube video of the pilot then you I
think you still would understand what's going on
and what the parameters are and what world we're
in that's true I didn't even oh my God it's so
loud Roxy what's happening I didn't even think
about it like that in that context and you're
so right cuz like oh what was I'm really glad
we watched the pilot cuz I felt like that made
it exceptionally easier just to like get on board
get into the groove of it right away it's almost
yeah that's definitely true it was like a pallet
cleanser easing us into this world so now we know
where we are yeah that was a really cool way to do
this um but the the advanc like you got a clear
because the last episode I mean the pilot it's
kind of weird to talk about it because the pilot
establishes Alistar alisar Alistar and he's kind
of like this wild card like can you trust him it
doesn't seem like you can actually trust this guy
right no of course not but they actually gave us
a direct villain in the version of this Adam Angel
which to me seems like Adam killed the angels to
to um you know speed up the uh the next cleansing
right that's what I'm thinking I don't I don't
think they actually killed an actual Angel you
mean Al you're saying that Adam killed an angel
to use it as an excuse to why they're going there
yeah when you talk about the pilot there was that
villain that we didn't see in episode one though
the snake guy oh yeah yeah yeah I but it wasn't
like the real villain no just it's interesting
that they clearly it's like I love that they kept
the parts of the pilot that I wanted them to and
then they retooled it to be like we need a big
bad we need like our entire story arc and what
are we doing here um also putting in to place like
the the seeds about the mom the dad how long this
has been who is actually riding for our princess
of hell you know I do like that relationship with
her bestie I am curious if this is a a romantic
relationship or just a bestie s yeah I think it
might just be a bestie but the show's very queer
which I really like a lot too it's so difficult I
can't not picture Harley Quinn and Poison Ivy so
that's why I feel like it's bordering on romance
oh yeah because I can't get it out of my head
they're so Harley and Ivy to me in a lot of ways
be I feel like there's probably going to be Alex
Brightman is the guy you keep asking about can
you show me his face yeah dude I'd be so happy
to show you his face anything to keep you have
what is this oh I do know this guy where do I
know him from I oh Beetle Juice the musical he
this is a guy whose voice is so distinct that
was interesting the voice actors are great in
this um they were great in the pilot but they're
great in this also do you think they're better do
you want to put the other ones to shame do you
want to put the other ones down from the pilot
I don't I couldn't do you no no I was just trying
to set you up to get hate comments but didn't take
the bait oh no no I couldn't I think that they
were all great yeah they're all great this is
I do Wonder one of my Curiosities about the start
of this is um now God damn it Roxy now I need to
know like who have I've seen this guy before he
does look so familiar uh Blue Bloods he's done a
lot of shows Dracula Teen Titans Go he's Beetle
juu and that so not Beetle juu and music seen
interviewed before which I watched okay okay so
what I what I am curious about because some of the
they did have some lines in here that seemed like
they were a response to certain YouTube comments
that came in like the the uh fluff boobs yeah
cuz I because that's where I would get confused
sometimes too cuz I thought they were boobs I was
like is this like a a trans car what am I looking
at you know no cuz they they said that it was a um
a drag queen oh okay in the OR at least they they
didn't say that in episode one it was happening
so zigzagging bad when they were standing outside
of the car and getting thrown the car before
the angel dust drug purchase yeah um and uh
they were like something you don't like a some
like something something in drag or whatever so
I think that they were saying it was a drag queen
must m not okay no sometimes the lines were going
by so fast and my mind was also keeping up with
like the animation I was so dazzled by the visuals
you know yeah and also I don't know what they're
pulling from the pilot into episode one what are
you talking about the whole it's one week later
after the pilot no I know but maybe they you know
sometimes they Ditch things that don't work and so
who knows maybe it is now I well that was one of
my my Curiosities that after we're done watching
I want to look up be because the this director of
it whose name is the same as the writer Vivian oh
and then the channels like Vivy pops or something
like that okay so Vivian um okay vivz pop is the
YouTube channel she's had this is coming out four
years later but it takes like a year to put like
an animation show together at minimum right like
especially something like on this caliber so I am
curious a how long did it take for them to develop
this show the actual Prime video show and B um
the I'm trying to and B and B you got it and B
um how much did change over the course of because
it seems like they kind of gave her a cart blunch
on everything she can do especially when you're
partner with a24 who generally lets you kind of
just do whatever the hell you want so I am curious
what did change from the original plan cuz what
I'm getting at is like usually when there's a
pilot they have like other episodes in mind or
or maybe an outline maybe scripts right and their
show Bible what changed like and that's kind of
what I was talking about too exactly about just
now what the overarching the what the season's
going to be what the show's going to be which
characters are the good guys bad guys who has
Redemption well I like it from this perspective
and where you actually see that cuz you know it
it's taking place in hell and the general rule
of thumb is that the hell bad Heaven good and
I like when they mess with Concepts in in shows
or movies where you actually take the angels and
you pose them as not such Angelic figures these
deities have been propped up almost the way how
like they deconstruct or or or uh interpret like
Greek gods you know like they think they're all
high and mighty but really they're like kind of
corrupt and messed up and that's what I like the
the version of the Angel aspect and also yeah the
question the a that that that con that's one of
the concepts of of religion uh when it comes
particularly to hell that that I've always had
a a struggle with wrapping my head around is that
you know like what warrants someone being I mean
if you're like truly horrendous like Hitler or
like yeah okay yeah you should be but this idea
of like not living by a certain guideline of the
Bible or whatever to to punish forever MH I in
in the in torturous hell with no opportunity for
Redemption yeah I think that that's interesting
and and one of the things I really liked from
the pilot to this first episode is what the
first episode has you question is if you can't get
out of your circumstances is there any point in
changing who you are just to be a better version
of you right and so you think about that from the
hell perspective Ive but what this first episode
does is shows us that clearly people who have gone
to heaven they were they really virtuous or were
they doing all of these good things on earth to
get to heaven and then once you get to heaven if
you can't be uh damned to hell is there any point
in continuing to be a good person exactly and so
while they're in heaven they clearly have changed
their ways and gone to their true nature because
they weren't being good to be good they were being
good to make it to heaven and so we're watching
these people who are doing who now are more evil
than the people in hell because they already have
been placed and that means that who they are in
their soul probably deserve to put them in hell
even though they did more good actions while they
were on Earth and there's also the egotism of do
me a favor can you look up if egotism is a word
yeah hit Apple tea hit Apple tea you really need
me too yeah I I just need to know hit the Apple
button and what's the Apple button some with the
Apple icon on it see says Apple command I could
have said a command I could have done that but I
I wasted your time uh egotism egotism is a word
right you know I had something looked up yes yes
okay egotism thank you egotism everyone everyone
egotism is a word the egotism of that moment the
ego of what what do you mean made me go away from
the thing I had looked up to tell you no what are
you talking about I looked something up it was on
there I wanted to tell you about it what did you
look up what I looked up was the girl Vivien who
made the series she is listed on her IMDb first as
a voice actress so I was like who did she voice in
the series because she's a voice actress first
and it just says various voices in the show but
it doesn't say anybody specifically it just says
various voices so I'm interested to see who who
she is what she actually sounds like oh so it it
must be kind of the way how like Seth McFarland
voices a bunch of characters but instead of
doing the main characters they probably do
a bunch of the like secondary random characters
like okay seems like that anyway go ahead egotism
um yeah so heaven I'm going to stay on track my
ego Will Make Me That by by getting into heaven
it seems like there is an egotism that does form
a pridefulness that we are better than because we
have made it and watching that Pride leading to
their fall ultimately I I'm I feel like there's
like a cool world that they have built here on the
in the afterlife that could lead to like kind of a
catastrophic uh event in some way like I think
there's some cool Universe building stuff with
just a bunch of musicals and jokes in between
when none of that matters Rox and are here for
serious conversations the music was so good I mean
that was really really well done it was better I
like like the music and the pilot but I I thought
the music was even stronger in this first episode
I had more money they could produce the [__]
I make it broad that's not a knock on the pilot
that's just I thought that this was like let's go
yeah that I can imagine she probably got a little
bit more help with uh constructing that because
that straight up seemed I love when it's like ju
supposed with having um you know music that sounds
like a Disney Disney song but you're getting just
the most um uh lavish nightmarish deviant violent
imagery to place it against like the wallpaper on
while she's singing so joyous I had a great time
with that I like I I like I really like the pilot
I I like this even more um I think it's a great
I think it's off to a great start me too I love
fish out of water stories that's kind of what
we have with her but she's also the connector of
these two worlds curious to see where we go yeah I
think it'll end with a post with with with her Dad
or Mom showing up Lilith and the season yeah and
then uh Lilith has been gone for seven years so
something must have happened little return she'll
be the ending scene all righty guys what did you
like this first episode more than the pilot don't
let your Nostalgia Cloud your judgment that's not
to say that you're wrong if you like the pilot
more I'm just just want you to have an honest
just setting the rules of opinions you got to just
really set it if you don't agree with me you're
wrong that's how it opinion Works in my mind
I agree with that so I'm right cuz I agree cuz
you agree with me I'm run a tight ship around here
people let's watch episode dose rockan here we go
one more time call you Rocky sometimes who mostly
horror and picture show those are people's names
yep I think I like this bit those are
my friends my friends hor picture show
yeah and bboa someone asked this question
before is this is this a joke you've done
before no why do should I tweak it yeah
I think we should Workshop it a little
bit that was an unexpected answer
all right all right we're out atie